Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність друзі Що ж ми робимо
взагалі Ну ми взагалі розуміємо що в нас
відбувається Я шокований цією постановою
ми пропонуємо включити представники
фопзж в ключові парламентські комітети
це після 24 лютого Ні ну В нас є якесь
розуміння Ми там гауляйтерів та
невдавчихся тому що до їхніх областей не
дійшли включаємо ключові парламентські
комітети так давайте не зупинятися
давайте баліцького включимо в комітет по
тег давайте включимо медведчука в
комітет по зовнішніх справах Він же нас
зараз зовні займається там якимось
справами так давайте його офіційно
включимо може дамо посаду медведчуку
нічого зупинятися Ну це ж якесь абсурд
Ми кажемо кожне в засіданні ради
починаємо з того що в нас загинули
хвилина мовчання Слава Україні і в цей
же час
русский мир в українському парламенті і
ще й посади їм даємо ви будете за це
голосувати Ну як це можна пояснити людям
поясніть мені Верховній Раді України
лежить проект постанови підписаний мною
Володимиром марієвим Софію фединою і
вашим колегою слугою народи дундою
грядяки передбачає вигнати із ПСЖ з
Верховної Ради є всі підстави вони
писали заяви про вихід з фракції опзж Це
пряма підстава позбавити їх мандатів
замість того щоб відправити їх Витя і
п'ятій колонії де є те посади що ви ще
їм дасте ви говорите що в нас не
конструктивна співпраця Ну це ж і
божевілля своїми руками агентів
московських розставляти давати їм
інформацію посади Я не знаю ми дійшли до
краю друзі Схаменіться прямо зараз Не
робіть дурню
нарешті-решт прийміть відповідальне
рішення тут теж є фронт всередині і
зрадником не місце в українському
парламенті